so he competed in his division which is
the plus 99 kilos and in the super fight
against Andre gova that's correct uh
this was in fact the first time in in
history that this was uh allowed
um for your uh listeners who don't
follow grappling
um we may have been very rude and just
throwing a lot of stuff at you without
explaining ourselves first of all ADCC
is like the Olympics of grappling uh it
occurs every two years
um you can either qualify for the event
through winning matches and a
qualification process or you can be
invited the only people who get invited
are either former winners or people in
the sport who are just widely recognized
superstars who bring some kind of brand
value who have proven in the past that
they have what it takes to compete at
that level
in this format there are two kinds of
matches
there are
weight division matches
in which you compete against people your
own uh uh roughly your own size and
weight
there is an open weight where anyone of
any size can enter so you can have very
small people fighting very large people
and there is a second category called a
super fight where established Champions
who have won previous open weight uh uh
tournaments
fight each other in one-off battles one
athlete against another so in most of
the matches you will you will fight
repetitively over time towards a gold
medal but in one category you fight one
fight the so-called super fight which is
usually the headline fight of the event
um traditionally if you were in the
Super fight you could not compete in the
weight categories
it was seen as too risky because you
might get injured
during the weight category or you might
have to fight for very tough fights in a
row and get exhausted so that you're
ineffective during the main event of the
uh of the show the super fight
so throughout its history ADCC has
always resisted the idea of an athlete
being allowed to do both weight category
and uh super fight it's never happened
before
Gordon Ryan requested to be able to do
this
um because of his extraordinary stature
in the sport
the ADCC organization granted his
request that was the first time ever
in addition Gordon Ryan would be
fighting to be the first person to win
three gold medals in three different
weight categories this has never been
done before
so it was a huge event on Gordon's part
and bear in mind also that prior to this
event he had fought just a month and a
half earlier against
a former ADCC open weight champion
Felipe Pena who had defeated in the past
and a completely different rule set and
then previously that against the current
world champion so there had been a build
up to this so he had been very active
uh uh coming up to the event and then he
went in to fight arguably the greatest
ACC champion of all time Andre Galvan
which would occurred late on Sunday and
would have to fight
the toughest people including uh the
possibility of fighting his Nemesis
Felipe Pena in the weight division prior
to getting to the Super fight so there
was genuine concern here that he may
have completely overstepped himself
um the biggest concern I had as a coach
and I'm sure the organizers Mo Jessica
must have had the same concern so he
would get injured or exhausted fighting
in his weight division
there were two athletes in particular uh
Felipe Pena who had given Gordon a very
tough 40-minute match and a no rules
setting
um uh shortly before ADCC and his former
training partner uh Nick Rodriguez
um who were expected to give Gordon very
very tough matches if they came up
against each other
so
there was a genuine concern that Gordon
made Burn himself out before he even got
to fight the guy who most people believe
was the greatest ADCC champion of all
time
so our concern was how do we manage this
so what we looked for is extremely
efficient methods of reducing the time
of the measures making the matches as
short as possible
um our favorite way to fight bigger
stronger athletes and I think Gordon was
the lightest athlete in his weight
division everyone goes all going so big
and strong is actually quite light
um uh I think he was outweighed by
almost all of his opponents
it's nice to see Gordon looking small
relative to his opponents which is
absurd to say but it is the open
division plus 99 kilos it was plus 99
kilos right that's what I mean sorry by
open plus 99 kilos everyone looks like
the Incredible Hulk yeah yeah so
um our big thing is when we fight bigger
stronger opponents we always go in two
directions you either go for the legs or
you go for the back and so
um we constructed strategies based
around those two methods so going for
submissions and we should also mention
that agcc rule said is for regular
matches I think it's five minutes and
five minutes total is 10 minutes and
then for finals matches it's 20 minutes
and half the time is spent with no
points
so these can be very very long matches
let me put this in a perspective modern
Judo matches five minutes a modern
wrestling match I believe is six minutes
in international freestyle
um so these matches can be 40 minutes
long now that's a long long grappling
match yeah and um depending on how you
compete in it that can have a huge tour
absolutely you can get to the finals and
just be absolutely spent so our whole
thing is okay Gordon's got to not only
get to the finals then he's got to fight
the toughest 80cc rapper of all time
after that so um we were looking for
quick and energy efficient matches and
that meant going to the back or going to
the legs
um and in the overwhelming majority of
cases that's exactly what he did he was
able to get some very very quick matches
uh courtesy of leglock finishes and in
the few cases where he uh he didn't
finish on legs then he would simply take
his opponents back and uh that's a very
low stress position to to occupy in one
case uh his opponent deliberately kept
his back on the ground to prevent the
back tag and he just chose mounted
position instead and so he was able to
go through his weight division with
extremely low energy expenditure which
set him up well to go into the uh the
finals no injuries very little energy
expenditure now it sounds easy to say
that you know oh okay the strategy
worked
but in order to get that strategy to
work you have to have one hell of a set
of skills